quand vous êtes las comme il vous aime
beaucoup on voulait vous rendre hommage
et ils vont tous rentrés en patineur
artistique
on va d'abord accueillir puisque ça va
être les championnats d'europe de
patinage artistique
le couple allemand avec gilles verdez et
christine mais kenny
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors franchement bravo bravo ces bocaux
hyper beau comme ça merci lecoufle même
version alors alors vous pouvez
commenter en fait un accord serait alors
on ne savait pas et quel moment on
allait pouvoir justement faire leur
introduction d'autant qu'elle est à
l'essai dans cette lettre il paraît
qu'en patinage il faut pas être trop
bavard en tout cas c'est ce que ma vie
là mais philippe environnement une fois
pour toutes nelson monfort mais elles
sont moins
c'est donc ce que j'essaye de faire mais
là à l'évidence c'est quand même un
leader dans ce court et c'est vrai une
suiveuse de qualité certes un petit peu
quand même un petit peu quoique sont en
couple à la fois sur glace mais aussi
dans la vie des commentaires ne le
regarde pas selon l'expression consacrée
écoutez ils étaient cinquante sixième du
classement au moment où ils ont pénétré
sur la glace on peut espérer peut-être
une ou deux places en mieux le couple
italien c'est vous qui allez les
présentait donc vous n'en chaîne avec
qui alors bon cher philippe nous
enchaînons donc avec un couple italien
qu'il est inutile de présenter c'est
donc pour ça que vous avez nous les
présenter jack et leurs héros accompagné
de la ravissante géraldine ya carbonara
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les oiseaux parce que
je tire parti de m
et là ça cassait chacun sait que c'est
très bon pour la ligne des patineurs
c'est patricia bouchon installez vous
vous êtes est vous êtes somptueux
mannie fresh & or si on avait des coups
comme ça à présenter patinage fait
encore plus d'audience
ça serait pas mal tout cas ça fait des
cartons d'audience sur france
télévisions on le rappelle c'est vrai
que ça marche très très très très fort
allez pour enchaîner avec le troisième
procès d'un couple espagnol
vous allez nous les présenter c'est vous
nelson alors oui nous attendons donc
vraiment et francesca pour l'espagne
[Applaudissements]
elle doit maintenant les favoris de la
compétition
[Applaudissements]
vous les découvrirez le fonds n'est pas
éliminatoire il peut se rattraper le
programme n'est pas complètement terminé
philippe qu'ils étaient favoris de la
compétition c'est dire le niveau
[Rires]
vraiment vraiment vraiment le pont de
bois il s'est pris une petite thalassa
il a failli perdre la boussole
il a failli perdre sa voûte allez on va
accueillir le dernier couple géré
exception des doyens de la compétition a
oui mais je dois ya de la compétition ce
sont les irlandais on voit pas souvent
des irlandais d'embrayage qui fêtait
jeudi de tête manquée calik arrivée
d'eau véloce ton présente maintenant
ciel
[Applaudissements]
chargée où la science
allez hop
[Applaudissements]
la fidélité des bornes wifi et s'est
fait mal mais on s'en fout mais ont
besoin
attendez attendez vous à déboîter
l'épaule à la paire larry cbl ah non
mais c'est le déséquilibre impose sa
dépendance et mordu la lèvre ce qu'on
voit là merci en tout cas il ya des
cascades dans cette émission
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
tout comme braga s'est en tout cas merci
la trame est tout chaud comme encore
beaucoup ce soir